I've got Mike McCarty in the house here
I'm standing in for Danny he's sick he
saw this it's the witcher expansion
hearts of stone hearts of stone and
we're gonna do a little video about it
the first thing I noticed is that you
meet up with shani again talk about
shani she's a cool character Johnny's a
scholar from Oxenford Academy she's
really smart she's smarter than Garrels
which is funny because their dialogue is
really funny that's great you get the
sense that she's kind of toning back her
vocab a little bit she's kind of trying
not to talk down to him even though she
could if she wanted to and Darryl kind
of picks up on that and seems a little
put off by that but it's kind of funny
because gerelds usually you know the
boss of every conversation yeah but
that's not the case here well it's great
they have a big history in the games as
well as the books and so it's cool to
see her pop up in this there's branching
quest lines a little bit and a lot of
them involve her corpse you kind of made
up with her and you it's unclear why
she's down in the sewers where you go
for the switcher contract yeah but
pretty much every character in this
expansion has ulterior motives and I
didn't even figure anything else out
because I played about a fifth of it
yeah that happens at the butcher yeah
I'm just sharp turns at every corner and
she really kind of unveils more that she
knows about as you go on and then you're
kind of wondering what she's really
doing so it's kind of a cool dynamic
especially considering she's definitely
a really smart character and she's
definitely smarter than Gerald so you
get the sense that maybe don't trust her
even though she's really an endearing
person and they have a history yeah but
you know like just with any other
character the expansion your kind of
wondering what is she really doing here
and what am i doing as far as the quest
that other people are giving me so what
speaking of the quests and the new
expansion it looked like you just go up
to the like a contract board and it
kicks it off are there a bunch of new
quest is a one big quest line like tell
me a little bit about the structure of
the hearts of stone yeah so it's
recommended for around level 30
characters ok so it's late game but you
don't have to have beaten the game you
can do it whenever you want um actually
I'm not clear if you know when it will
actually unlock but you could do it
before you beat the game or after so
kind of both cams of players should be
able to get into it buster yeah you
pretty much just go up and accept a
Witcher contract just like any other you
know beast bounty you might do during
the main game and you meet this guy
named ole geared Von Erich is this
really you know stout you know really
strong guy who's you know a good sword
fighter as you glade
now um he gives you this quest to go
hunt this beast down and you go into the
stores where you meet shawnee it's where
a lot more of the story kind of unfolds
and then all of a sudden a huge story
opens up like involving political
political intrigue this royal bloodline
the Von Erich ancestry you ghosts yeah
there's a lot of ghosts and there's some
really funny scenes involving a certain
ghost who nice may or not may not
possess you but Danny apparently did a
heist which I'm kinda disappointed I
didn't get to see but he would be able
to talk more about that the yeah can't
wait yeah stay tuned like you guys are
gonna talk about on the lobby so tune
him back for that on Tuesday one thing I
saw from it from what they gave us is
you're fighting like a wizard it looks
like you're fighting lots of go mini
bosses like I said we played two hours
and I think they're saying it's around
10 hours of new content being the first
major paid expansion nice and in that
two hours I felt like three bosses
including the beast that made you
mentioned yeah that's kind of when
things start getting a little foggy as
far as what certain characters want and
then I also fought someone else who may
or may not be immortal and I don't want
to spoil who that is cause it kind of
becomes this really cool like do all
like sword fight but past that I don't
know it at that pace it seemed like
there's gonna be a lot more bosses
because you played two hours and we
fought throttle yeah uh there's also
looks like a new like part of the AXI
ability um where it was chaining to
other people as you killed them it would
basically like jump to the next person
and keep them stoned which looked cool
um did they tell you about that or did
you guys have any experience like with
the signs are the new abilities do you
know anything about that no I did I had
no idea which is kind of makes me
excited to see what else I didn't know
about in the expansion cuz they pretty
much just gave us like 40 ability points
to just put however we wanted to in it
and I think there's a lot of stuff I
didn't see right and I'm sure they're a
lot of abilities I didn't see either
yeah and that's exciting cuz like not
only are you getting swathes of content
which The Witcher team is like
demonstrable amazing at producing
narrative stuff which I'm excited for
your getting new abilities which you
know the combat is pretty good in the
game so that's fun and we don't have to
wait too long to get
hands on it so comes out like the 13th I
think yeah octobre 13 you'll have the 10
new hours of content I'm sure just being
The Witcher and having a big world
you'll probably get more out of it than
that especially the new abilities and
everything yeah yeah I'm excited to play
it again I have the written preview up
today and you can check that out for a
little more in depth on like my
experience cool and then Danny and I
like you said we'll be talking on the
lobby and we can hear about his high
switch I'm excited to hear about it just
sounds like Grand Theft Auto in a
fantasy setting which what more can you
ask for yeah whereas I kind of went to
the wedding which was like a sitcom in a
fantasy broke which just as awesome in
certain ways Witcher 3 never never not
impressive yeah seems like I'm excited
cool